[موسيقى]
اذا مشاهدينا لم يدم الهدوء والحذر طويلا
في العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم اذا افاد
مراسل الجزيره بان مضادات الطيران التابعه
لقوات الدعم السريع ردت على طلعات جويه
لسلاح الجو السوداني في مدينه الخرطوم
بحري
من جهتهلال الجيش السوداني في بيان قبل
قليل انه نشر الافا من عناصر القوات
المسلحه ومن جهاز المخابرات والاحتياطي
المركزي لعمل مسح بري كامل لولايه الخرطوم
واضاف ان عمليه المسح تاتي بعدما وصفها
بنجاح عمليه حسم جوي استهدفت نقاط وجود
قوات الدعم السريه في الخرطوم فجر اليوم
فالمقابل قالت قواته الدعم السريع في بيان
من الخرطوم استفاقت في اول ايام العيد على
وقع قنابل الطائرات والمدافع الثقيله في
هجوم وصفته بالكاسح من الجيش استهدف احياء
سكنيه